we have been allowed into this military
hospital on the promise that we don't
give away its location except to say
that it's in eastern ukraine and back
from the front lines
they are worried because it could be
targeted by russian air strikes as other
hospitals here have been
the walking wounded limp the dimly lit
corridors alive but badly scarred by the
fight
behind the doors injured soldiers fill
the beds happy to have survived and
ready to tell us their stories
[Music]
not
and i understand that is
that is bad
the icu is now so busy they put beds in
the hallways
these patients are all suffering from
horrific burns caused by explosions
they're covered in yellow antiseptic
iodine to stop their wounds from
becoming infected
and many of them just lie still not
talking not moving but under heavy
sedation to dull the agonizing pain
all beds are busy
all beds
in
and
one floor more
than in a regular regime
so
in regular regime for example before
wall we have a center for 40 pets
just now we have twice
the number of soldiers being killed and
wounded every single day is huge too
great to sustain
[Music]
and yet every soldier we speak to says
they will go back and fight when they
recover
if they recover
because when you're fighting to defend
your own country your own people
the risk is worth it
alice debunker sky news in eastern
ukraine